first question we dealt with was the
management of our modern borders we set
up a unit a Rapid Reaction unit
containing 1500 people Wednesday of this
week this system has become operational
agreed reforms to be made to Euro deck
and fence to that the Maltese presidency
would be able to begin negotiations with
the / European Parliament I also want to
congratulate the presidency for reaching
agreement on the systematic checks at
our external borders for all citizens EU
and non-eu last week which we proposed
exactly one year ago this will be an
additional tool in our fight against the
threat of foreign terrorist fighters
yesterday we also reached an agreement
on the visa suspension mechanism in
record time and I invite the european
parliament and council now to give visa
liberalisation to Georgia and Ukraine
soon finally we made important progress
in our discussions on how to reform the
common European asylum system we need a
clear red dick table efficient but most
of all fair w system that enable us to
act in a structured and effective manner
both in times of calm and in times of
crisis